Welcome back everyone this will be my brand new
marvel secret invasion video there were a bunch
of big announcements recently a bunch of big
teasers so we'll break it all down if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos the i am groot episodes
are going to be starting on disney plus really
soon and then she-hulk episodes after that i'll
be doing videos for all those episodes just like
i do for all the other marvel disney plus series
but you probably saw a lot of the bigger news
outlets talking about the return of charlie cox's
daredevil vincent d'onofrio's kingpin during
marvel's echo episodes next year i just did
a bunch of videos about that so i'll link them at
the end of this and down in the description below
because that's just like the watershed moment of
like all these old characters coming back into the
mcu it's gonna feature a lot of them like the echo
series is gonna feel kind of like an unofficial
daredevil season four they're not the only old
characters that are also just confirmed to come
back kristin ritter's jessica jones is like the
next big one supposedly a little bit of that is
going to happen during the she-hulk episodes but
even more so like in a much bigger way during the
echo episodes next year we just saw them bring
ants and mount black bolt in the inhumans back
during doctor strange 2 multiverse of madness
canonizing that inhumans tv show legit to the mcu
if it wasn't already canon i know a lot of people
wonder about that the inhumans are definitely
canon to the marvel cinematic multiverse now
now the next big group that people have been
asking about are the agents of shield characters
primarily through chloe bennett's quake character
everybody's been asking about them posting
theories for the past couple of years since
we first heard that they might be bringing any
kind of characters back like the daredevil the
kingpin character back spider-man no way home
in the hawkeye series are really just like the
first big instances of that happening with
those big characters being made cannon again
so naturally when secret invasion was announced
at that big disney plus event people wondered if
chloe bennett's quake or any of the agents of
shield characters would be coming back because
they're so tied to the nick fury character if they
were planning on bringing all these characters
back through all the movies and the disney
plush shows this would be the place to do it
but what's changed recently is that about a year
ago when we first learned about daredevil coming
back naturally people started blowing up chloe
bennett's social media because charlie cox doesn't
have his own social media so people couldn't
bother him about stuff like this in the same way
so when people started blasting chloe bennett
about coming back she actually responded but
gave a total andrew garfield level response like
andrew garfield has turned himself into a verb
because of the way he responded to all those
rumors and leaks from spider-man no way home
sandra garfield playing spider-man again oh you
almost got me no no no i'm not i'm not i'm not
crying out loud i want to fight an alien i'm i'm
i'm still like that you fought an alien in space
they were actually pretty funny he said he
had a lot of fun lying to people about that
reportedly now what's changed is that chloe
bennett is supposed to actually be featured
or referenced somehow during the actual secret
invasion series like it's supposed to actually
be a real thing agents of shield was a marvel
television show made by a completely different
group of people when jeff lowe was in charge of
that kevin foggy wasn't really overseeing what was
happening at marvel television now they've changed
it so that all marvel television like all marvel
everything just kind of flows through kevin feige
so he says yes or no to pretty much everything now
that happened when they were creating disney
plus and it's why like all the brand new marvel
stuff is all canon to the mcu but when agents of
shield started back in 2012 alongside the original
avengers movie it was a very different situation
behind the scenes they had very different plans
remember how they planned to make that inhumans
movie it was on their marvel phase 3 schedule
for years in fact today as of me posting this
video july 12th it's the three year anniversary
to the day that the inhumans movie was supposed
to come out so everybody pour one out for the
movie that never was it would have come out right
after avengers end game there's a whole separate
story about why they got rid of that movie but the
too long didn't read of it all is that kevin feige
always wanted the x-men back in the day and the
inhumans were treated as like the next best thing
that they had the rights to like who's a weird
group of people with biological powers that we
can use the inhumans we have rights to that but
then obviously what happened is they knew that
they were going to get the x-men back eventually
so there was no reason to do an inhumans movie
and it did not help that the inhumans tv show
bombed so hard that kevin foggy just kind of
wanted to push it off into the corner and forget
about it that is until doctor strange too came
along and they had an opportunity to do inhumans
with the black bull character coming back but at
the same time that that crazy inhumans tv show
was going on back in the day they actually had
a really legit inhuman storyline during the agents
of shield series so chloe bennett's quake kind of
became like the top inhuman that they had featured
inside the marvel universe so naturally when they
announced all these disney plush shows it seemed
like a slam dunk to just bring her back the same
way that they brought daredevil all the netflix
characters but like the best of the marvel netflix
series like there were a lot of good things that
they did during agents of shield why not bring
some of that stuff back one of the main reasons
why you haven't seen her in the newer disney plus
shows yet though or the newer movies is mostly
just because they weren't ready to explain
inhumans inside the main 616 marvel universe yet
like i've been doing miss marvel episodes they
literally just swerved harder than you could
possibly swerve on kamala khan's miss marvel
inhuman backstory because they didn't want to do
that in the mcu now our backstory is much closer
to what you saw during the shangshi movie with
the 10 rings origin story the great protector
dragon this alternate race of beings from another
dimension the newer energy inside of her i'll talk
more about that during my miss marvel episode 6
finale video but now the closest thing we actually
have to legit inhumans inside the mcu the marvel
cinematic multiverse is that black bolt inhumans
cameo during doctor strange 2 in the 838 universe
and if it wasn't clear because of that professor
x cameo scene with all the x-men animated series
easter eggs all the regular mainstream x-men are
canon in that universe too even magneto they
talked about including magneto in that movie
but when you talk about agents of shield and what
was canon to the mcu like what the crossover was
because there was actually some crossover between
the movies and the tv show back in the day
nick fury himself even did a cameo scene in season
one coulson was also another major character and
they did a lot of stuff with the cree they're now
doing that with the captain marvel movie series
but the way the showrunners talked about that show
they treated it like the 838 universe cameo scenes
with black bolton inhumans like the showrunners
talked about it being in a completely separate
timeline and that's why they could mention all
the infinity war stuff thanos attacking earth when
that was happening a couple years ago while they
were also having their own world-ending threats
with all the inhumans characters it's kind of
like the eternals movie with the dead celestial
in the indian ocean like how come we haven't heard
other movies talking about that yet it's a giant
inhuman body just jutting out of the ocean think
about all the instagram influencers in real life
they'll be trying to get pictures of themself on
the dead celestial if they were treating it like
a real thing in the mcu people would not shut up
about it it'd be all over the news j jonah jameson
would somehow find a way to blame it on spider-man
but agents of shield being in a separate timeline
is why they could also do stuff like ghost
rider showing up with the darkhold without dr
strange showing up and also explaining how their
version of the darkhold looks so different from
the version of the darkhold that we saw in doctor
strange 2 enduring wan division there's been a lot
of talk about ghost rider coming back too i did
videos about that when moon night was happening
so i'll link some of those in the description
below too because eventually yes ghostwriter or
version of ghostwriter will come back they also
almost did a ghostwriter tv show like they were
literally getting ready to roll camera on sets for
the robbie reyes ghost rider tv show it's going to
be a spin-off of asians of shield but then kevin
feige cancels it when he started consolidating all
of marvel tv stuff under him and since then the
last couple of years you've just seen characters
slowly start coming back from the tv shows
piecemeal daredevil is just the beginning of that
the report now is that chloe bennett actually is
coming back daredevil's style through the secret
invasion series and will probably show up in
future related stuff because of the way they
treated the daredevil series canon on the netflix
episodes when charlie cox came back and spiderman
no way home i think it'll be a similar situation
when chloe bennett eventually comes back and
because they destroyed shield during the captain
america winter soldier movie and we haven't had it
so far but nick fury has been super active since
then i think they'll just say chloe bennett and
any of her related agents of shield characters
have been active working for nick fury on the dl
this whole time doing all the same stuff handling
all the same kind of threats on the dl though and
they just won't specifically reference too many
things during the events of the agents of shield
series the same way that they did with daredevil
when he first came back like when charlie cox
actually came back during his scenes they made no
mention of the events of daredevil season three he
just makes jokes about his special ability and
how he was a really good lawyer the big report
right now with the secret invasion series is that
it's going to be about a faction of scrolls that
have gone bad and are trying to infiltrate earth
so it'll be similar to the secret invasion comic
book series but it won't be like a giant avengers
level event like the big tagline in the comics was
who do you trust and it was the idea that any
of the big a-list avengers characters could be
scrolls any like the major major characters during
the series it'll be a smaller group of characters
and it sounds like it's going to be a faction of
religious zealots that will be trying to invade
earth the big report now too is that emilia clarke
is playing the scroll empress who was a main
character during the comic book secret invasion
series it'll all connect back to what nick fury
was doing during the spider-man far from home
post-credits scene on the scroll space station
like they'll finally be paying that off how long
has it been since we've seen that it's been years
they'll also probably be some kind of miss marvel
post credit scene like we saw during one division
with monica rambo like monica rambo got her own
version of a post credit scene this sort of tied
to the captain marvel 2 movie the marvels it'll
probably be the same situation with miss marvel
because this is what her movie costume is supposed
to look like they've already shot the marvels
movie so it'll connect to that but because nick
fury will also be a big part of that too we'll
also probably see some connection to the secret
invasion series too and what he's been doing these
past couple of years marvel comic-con is coming
in the next week they're going to be dropping a
bunch of trailers like the black panther 2 trailer
a bunch of trailers for the upcoming disney plus
series i'll do videos for all that stuff so make
sure you enable alerts for my channel so you don't
miss that they'll also be another comic-con
type of event for the tv shows in september
like we saw the past couple of years where they
just hype up the upcoming marvel disney plus
stuff we'll also probably get a secret invasion
trailer during that will you wait for everything
everyone click here for all my thor love and
thunder alternate ending and deleted scenes and
click here for my full thor love and thunder post
credit scene video for hercules and all the other
really big characters my next video will also
be my full miss marvel episode 6 finale video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!